i have a daughter
um she's one years old she'll be two in
january and
i know
that if
my story ends in baltimore and we stay
in baltimore and she goes through the
schools and she goes through whatever
programs and she does whatever she's
whatever she's into
in her life somebody's gonna stop her
and they're gonna say
yo
your father gave books to my school your
father visited my school your father was
the person who helped my whatever get
started their writing career he got them
agent he put money in a pocket he he we
was on the air mattress he bought us the
bed with the box spring and the [ __ ]
prosthopedic all that [ __ ] like yo he's
that [ __ ] like yo i love him like your
father changed my whole [ __ ] and then i
know that somebody's gonna be like yo
your father
[ __ ] brought the violence from down
the hill to the projects this gun plays
here because of what him and his friends
did they [ __ ] the neighborhood up they
did terrible [ __ ] he doesn't deserve
anything
and
god willing if i'm around i'm gonna have
to explain that to her i'm gonna have to
tell her like yo the stuff that i do a
lot of it is a result of someone not
just the pain i went through but the
pain i caused and then there's a healing
process that i'm going to be going
through for the rest of my [ __ ] life
so
get off your high horse and get off your
oh my god he's a black literary [ __ ]
that [ __ ] because you have to i have to
say
that
i'm not perfect i've been a bad person
i've done some horrible things and i've
tried my best to make amends for that
and i know i'm going to be working on
that [ __ ] for the rest of my life some
[ __ ] that i did as a teenager in my
early 20s it's some [ __ ] i'm going to be
trying to fix when i'm [ __ ] 60 70 80
years old